ma voix d'outre-tombe et elle est due à
un gros rhume vous vous êtes là en bonne
forme et j'espère et on va passer une
heure et quart ensemble mondiaux c'est
presque d'actualité vous avoir réussi
sur un plateau de télévision à quelques
jours du débat sur l'avortement à
l'assemblée et je ne voudrais pas que
cette émission soit placée uniquement
sous le signe de la mort te ment des
viols et autres procès femme alors on
parlera de tas de choses qui vous sont
chers nous aurons marek halter peintre
et écrivain qui viendra à nous dire
quelques mots sujet des jeux olympiques
de moscou pour lesquels ils proposent
une action dont il nous parlera tout
al'air charlotte de turckheim qu'on a
surnommé la coluche féminine viendra
nous donner quelques échantillons de son
talent et vous faire rire j'espère à la
marion jouera pour nous du bac et du 2
bis si alain cances et là comme
d'habitude prêts à vous piquer et cabu à
vous croquer alors d'abord avant toute
chose c'est ce n'était pas une mauvaise
semaine pour les femmes quand même
la présidente de la bolivie lydia
wagerer le prix goncourt féminin
savourer jouer oui mais enfin c'est
moins simple que ça l'une des femmes je
veux dire il suffit pas qu'il est une
présidente et un prix goncourt
je suis fier parce que le bonheur est là
d'où il est renvoyé pour ces deux
objectifs
bon on commence par quelques notes
biographiques je vous les donne
et vous rectifié éventuellement vous
êtes né à carthage en tunisie en 1927 de
pernes origines berbères et de mère
juive dans une société pauvre où il ne
faisait pas bon être fille
à tel point que votre père a caché à ses
amis votre naissance pendant quinze
jours
très tôt vous refusez la condition de
femme qui vous est promise vous vous
rouler par terre fait la grève de la
faim pour refuser les travaux ménagers
poursuivez vos études contre vents et
marées dit non au mariage arrangé qui
aurait fait de vous une épouse à 15 ans
est une maman à 16 exactement comme
votre mère vous partez pour la france
pour suivre vos études à la fac de droit
juris le jour et standardiste la nuit
vous découvrez le racisme à l'université
où vous êtes tout à la fois l'habit
côté-là youpine une autre découverte est
celle d'une grossesse non désirée
vous êtes enceinte à 19 ans et c'est
votre premier avortement combien
traumatisant alors bon c'est vrai que
votre jeunesse peut expliquer beaucoup
de choses sans faire de mauvaises
psychanalyse mais votre situation des
quand même particulière des dans une
société particulière et toutes les
filles ne sont pas dans cette situation
là des solos et oui je crois qu'on l'a
on la retrouve en changeant un peu les
choses pour beaucoup de femmes
aujourd'hui mais ce qu'on voudrait bien
parce que c'est que mon enfance a été
quand même très heureuses je sais que ça
paraît contradictoire mais était pleine
de soleil de mer de football est plein
de sa part est aussi extraordinaire j'ai
eu des problèmes avec mes parents qui
considérait que je sais pas qui est un
petit peu anormal de ne pas vouloir me
marier de vouloir étudier mais je n'ai
pas été mal aimé j'étais très aimé par
mon père et ma mère que j'aime
tendrement il me reste ma mère
maintenant et survit depuis que mon père
est mort et je dois dire que cette
enfance au fond ça pose un problème
parce que c'est une enfance
affectivement effectivement les hnwi
avec beaucoup de lumière et de soleil et
et avec quand même cette espèce de de
révolte parce que c'était comme ça les
filles c'était c'était pas bien et l'on
vous êtes vous avez voulu devenir
avocate pour pourquoi pour défaut pour
vous révolter contre dsk pour plaider
pour vous oui je pensais qu'il fallait
que oui je me défende que j'apprenne et
puis c'est vrai que j'avais envie et par
la suite je crois que ça s'est beaucoup
vu c'est que j'avais envie non pas de
deux plaidé les petites choses pour
demander pardon ou l'indulgence où
j'avais envie de justement de de dire
pourquoi il ne faut pas qu est
d'humilier d'offenser pourquoi les
l'oppression c'est pas bon pourquoi
c'est la loi qu'il faut accuser plutôt
que se laisser accuser par elle et c'est
un petit peu mon chemin et le racisme
c'est vrai que vous l'avez découvert à
nu et la cité oui enfin je l'aï
découvert d'abord en tunisie vont
obliger tu es dans un pays colonisé
était monté ctera et c'est là de la
première prise de conscience la fille ou
l'arabe ou le juif dont ce pays là ce
protectorat français c'est un petit peu
la même chose c'était d'aider soudain
peu des sous c'est 30 et accumulé à
s'intégrer une chose à la fois
et puis là mais j'ai toujours pensé ça
c'est
à la fois l'aliénation de la culture et
le bien fait parce que c'est vrai que je
suis de culture presque totalement
française je parle l'arabe mais je ne
sais ni l'écrire et je parle arabe qu'on
écrit pas puisque je parle arabe de la
rue eh bien j'avais cette espèce d'idée
très longtemps cru en moi que c'était on
a retrouvé son monde l'algérie
d'ailleurs que les mauvais français
c'était les français kiki colonisés mais
que les bons la vraie france celle de la
révolution des droits de l'homme de
l'égalité du go de voltaire de pascal et
bien elles n'étaient pas comme ça quand
j'ai dit oui à 17 ans pour la à la
sorbonne et au droit et bien j'ai eu un
grand choc parce que quand je dis mes
origines immédiatement ça a été enfin le
plus gentiment du monde on dirait ça se
voit pas
vous me direz pas ou bien quand il y
avait des discussions un peu plus
succéder à l'époque aussi la femme de
droit était aux mains de ses mains de
vox et la guerre c'est ça 45 c'est d
autres enfin je veux dire il ne faisait
pas bon et discuter de d'égalité ou
d'anti racisme a changé moi parler au
nom des fils un multiplayer te remets
sauf pour faire des conférences
il ya des endroits où ça n'a pas changé
je crois que assas par exemple ray été
décommandé deux ou trois fois que de lui
faire des conférences et finalement vous
savez on vous dit qu'on n'est pas en
mesure d'assurer votre sécurité qui vaut
mieux que vous veniez par dont convient
pas j'enchaîne vous commencé à plaider
au barreau de tunis tribunaux militaires
procès politique membre du collectif
d'avocats du fln pendant la guerre
d'algérie vous défendez entre autres
djamila boupacha jeune algérienne
torturés violés et vous êtes arrêté vous
même le lendemain du 13 mai 58 parle aux
as et le colonel godard bataille contre
la torture et pour les droits de l'homme
toujours vous assistez aux procédés
nationaliste basque à burgos en 1970 et
vous vous battez pour eva forest arrêtés
et torturés dans les prisons de franco
une bataille politique puisque vous
présenter aux élections législatives au
temps de la fédération la gauche en 1967
à paris
bataille pour les femmes et c'est le
plus connu l'avortement à bobigny
le viol jugée pour la première fois aux
assises comme un crime avec ce choisir
association mixte on oublie quelquefois
fourni en 71 avec simone de beauvoir
christiane rochefort et jean rostand
le programme commun des femmes et les
candidatures féministes dont la voûte
d'ailleurs en mars 78 à cela j'ajoute
les livres des cours des conférences un
mari trois fils vous arrivez j'essaye
mais ce que je vais vous dire d'abord
que 158 j'étais arrêté après le coup de
force du 13-mai n'y avait pas encore
l'ol s'est ténue c'était il faut bien
dire général de gaulle et l'ouest est un
épiphénomène du gaullisme est venu par
la suite et pour laisser ce soit parce
que vous étiez à prendre parce que je me
suis trouvée bloquée je plaidais je
plaidais ce jour là le 13 mai pour un
responsable du fln se souvient d'abord
d'ailleurs d'avoir eu son acquittement
et puis on a tout coupé vous savez il y
avait plus de départ vers la france
alors j'essayais d'aller en tunisie puis
en algérie quand on a trouvé tous ses
billets dans mon sac on a déjà essayé de
m'enfuir
et en fait c'était absurde ont été des
atouts les avocats n'allait en algérie
que s'il avait une autorisation de la
préfecture de police que l'on vous
délivrer la demande du bâtonnier donc
j'étais parfaitement en règle simple
j'étais dans ma mission d'avocats mais
il est vrai d'avocats du fln est là si
vous voulez le 13 mai les masques sont
tombés je veux dire il n'y avait plus de
droits de la défense je me souviens toi
que c'est amusant à dire j'avais dans
mon sac un télégramme de convocation du
président petit puisque je devais
soutenir un recours en grâce sur les
sorties en disant je suis convoqué alors
on m'a dit vous savez la république
1 je parlais de votre lutte qui est le
plus connu votre lutte pour les femmes
est-ce que ce que vous n'êtes pas
toujours un peu las de plaider toujours
la même chose de revendiquer toujours et
toujours
droits pour les femmes à une plus juste
l'égalité si j'ose dire
vous savez quand la même chose on l'a
pas obtenue d'une part et quand la même
chose c'est vraiment très essentiel pour
la moitié du genre humain
non je veux pas lasser et puis
finalement contrairement à ce qu'on peut
penser on ne dit pas la même chose parce
que contrairement à ce qu'ont ce qu'on
dit il n'ya pas vous voyez vraiment j'ai
l'impression que rien n'est jamais
acquis aux femmes dans leur lutte
il ya vous avez des avancées et puis
deux pas en arrière alors il faut
recommencer
l'explication parce que je voudrais je
crois que je veux convaincre
je n'aime pas la violence je vais
expliquer je veux convaincre alors je
reprends mon explication mais c'est pas
vraiment la même
et vous n'avez pas l'impression qu'il y
a comme il ya une crise morale politique
économique à une crise du féminisme ou
est ce qu est ce que le combat pour le
féminisme est toujours aussi d'actualité
quand le monde va si mal
ou parce que moi si mon nom c'est à dire
que je crois que pour le féminisme il ya
il ya un changement urgent et nécessaire
à faire un qualitatif il ya un moment
qui était très nécessaire ou les femmes
qui n'avaient jamais eu la parole qui
ont été étouffés dans dans leur vie dans
leur dans leur histoire les femmes ont
dit vous savez on dit que que l'homme
fait l'histoire et que la femme est
l'histoire ce qui est monstrueux devrait
à la fois faire l'histoire et les
lettres et bien les femmes ont eu besoin
de parler ça c'est d'appeler d'un terme
peu galvaudé dire son vécu mais ça
suffit pas alors moi je pense que il
faut changer
je veux dire on sera content c'est très
bien on avait besoin de s'enrichir
mutuellement nos expériences et
d'apprendre d'abord à parler parce que
moi qui vais militer à la fois dans un
mouvement de femmes et dans et qui
connaît enfin les instances politiques
mixte je vois je vois qu'une femme ailée
muette quand il ya des hommes qui sont
là prêts à la censure et même même de
leurs yeux et puis quand elles parlent
entre elles mais les hommes ne seront
jamais ce que sont des femmes entre
elles qui commence à parler donc c'était
nécessaire parce qu'ils ont le sentiment
que c'est un peu une wii un peu passé un
peu je pense passer une vitesse à la
réflexion c'est ce qu'on a essayé de
faire un et ce qu un changement
qualitatif et puis un peu et ça ça
manque théorisé vous veillez un petit
peu la lutte des femmes lutte des femmes
féminisme et socialisme féminisme et
libéralisme le féminisme à skis avec une
stratégie alors parce qu'après on nous
accuser peut-être ce qui veut dire qu'on
fait comme ça du coup par coup ce qui
est d'ailleurs faux parce que le coup
par coup des femmes c'est comme
l'iceberg internes ont je veux dire
c'est ce qu'on voit on voit le coût par
mois au mais c'est tout les racines de
de la société qui sont mises en cause
pouvaient prendre l'exemple que vous
voulez des luttes des femmes et je vous
dirai ce que ça remet en cause le dirai
pas parce que vous l'aurez centives même
la contraception l'avortement discute
pour dix ou douze semaines c'est pas
vrai c'était d'ailleurs c'est à dire le
droit à l'amour c'est faire éclater
l'hypocrisie la double morale sexuelle
en femme dire que quand on fait l'amour
on a un enfant obligatoirement où on est
à une meurtrière enfin ça c'est donc le
préalable à tout changement de société
oui le plein de qualités le préalable
c'est de savoir que le ponctuel dans la
lutte des femmes imbriquent si vous
voulez des changements des racines de la
société donc des hommes ça c'est très
important les hommes ne comprendront
jamais à quel point ils devraient être
parties prenantes j'arrive charge en a
quelques-uns qui espère dépasser assez
vraiment leur bataille à 51 ans vous
êtes selon un sondage une des femmes les
plus célèbres et les boys 1 50
donc vous êtes selon un sondage une des
femmes les plus célèbres et les plus
influentes de france vous avez beaucoup
demi des personnalités comme sartre
aragon témoins votre mariage guy bedos
ou miu miu
mais des femmes anonymes aussi qu'ils
trouvent à choisir ou dans votre cabinet
accueil chaleur et consultations parfois
gratuite
vous avez des ennemis aussi même parmi
certaines femmes qui vous reprochent
quelquefois votre modération votre
réformisme à côté de l'image publique
que vous donnez succès charme
épanouissement une question revient sous
la pluie de vaud portraitiste alors ça
j'en ai trouvé en pagaille qu'est ce qui
vous fait courir
êtes vous aussi forte qui lui paraît
quand ils n'ajoutent pas alors là ce
sont vraiment des phallocrate et ça
paraît évident quand on a tout pour soi
comment peut-on être féminine
vous répondez encore à ce genre de
choses non vraiment mais oui donc je
vais dire simplement ça me rappelle
quand même l'histoire de pourquoi qu'est
ce qui me fait courir en fait j'ai envie
de dire je cours pas je vis alors très
bonne tout mais ce que je veux dire
comme caisse pourquoi fait-elle sajoo
vous dire ce à quoi ça me fait penser
devant un tribunal militaire en algérie
lorsque je plaide pour des fln je me
souviens d'un commissaire du
gouvernement absolument charmant un
genre instituteur vous voyez qui était
très sensible le fait que je cite et
victor hugo quelqu'un d'autre et on
bavarde et dans les dents les délibérés
et ne participez pas et il est venu me
dire un jour après le bavardage comme ça
mais avec presque de l'amitié de la
colère mais vous êtes comme ça vous avez
des enfants vous êtes intelligent mais
comment une femme comme vous peut-être
défendre les arabes et je trouve c'est à
peu près la même chose pourquoi se
battent pourquoi si vous voulez
réfléchir pourquoi font savoir une cause
entre guillemets parce que j'aime pas
beau
quand on peut s'orienter autrement c'est
à peu près le même raisonnement on a une
image de vous très sûr de vous est ce
que c'est vrai ce stade où est-ce que
non mais ce que vous connaissez nout
enfin je pense que bien sûr bien sûr
bien sûr je suis pas sûr de moi bien sûr
je connais toute la fatigue et
découragement je vais bien sûr on a
aujourd'hui on m'a bien maquillé ses
commandes
alors on a essayé de vous suivre à
travers vos multiples activités vous
suivre pendant toute une journée on a
choisi non-lieu quelques-unes on n'a
délibérément pas pris le palais parce
que c'est dire le plus connu alors on va
voir le reste oui le cabinet je vais
toujours eu dans mon appartement et
j'étais obligé de le faire parce que
travaillant très jeune avec des enfants
très jeunes ça m'a permis de tout faire
la fois cette femme qui refuse de donner
son sang
l'exercice du droit de visite du père
scalpeur épuisé - violeur ses
impressions catégorie plume hier soir et
qui a été condamné ça vient dans la
corbeille
mais ces événements la cour d'appel mais
nous avons déposé une plainte contre
l'armée puis j'ai l'impression que ça
veut pas se payer parce que la place ne
progresse pas tellement finalement et
puis il faut qu'on prenne une décision
pour
la position adoptée ou bien bien on y va
ou bien on fait moyer je crois qu'il
faut qu'on fasse attention si vous
demandez un renvoi à nouveau ici parce
que nous avons une affaire de viol qui
tombe à bobigny au mois de janvier donc
il faudrait pas que des affaires tombent
en même temps parce que la sphère
d'assises de bobigny sera impossible de
la renvoyer veut dire qu'elle contrôle
du vieux je suis allé prendre à bobigny
l'arrêt dans la sphère qui est passé 10
oui les trois policiers c'est mon père
qui m'a et on est reçu partie civile
pour ça c'était pas tort oui parce que
ça fait une jurisprudence
avant la loi
la cuisine est belle je ne passe ça
j'aime pas ça que je la fait pas alors
comment on pourrait la faire enfin le
temps mais en revanche de temps en temps
et pour des amis mais pour des amis
comme beaucoup vous des mots pour cela
je fais un couscous parce que là ça me
prend presque deux journées de de ma vie
mais avec beaucoup de joie c'est sûr
tourner comme ça je le fais comme ma
grand mère m'avait appris à le faire
c'est très longes roule
et puis c'est comme quand je n'ai pas
une bonne régression je me sens bien et
puis c'est bon pour leur pipi contre les
murs quelquefois même sur leurs
chaussures qui c'est debout ça les
rassure les hommes
où
sont leurs petits jets horizontale leur
petit siphon l'heure de ma balle et à la
bataille navale dit les hommes
ce sont leurs p'tits ceps dans leur
culotte leurs coûts périscope sous la
flotte sur le bateau la carotte les
hommes
oh
et au don de ce pool bidoche qui leur
pend douce ou la brioche et feront des
guerres et pour les meilleurs les hommes
comme ils se racontent leurs conquêtes
leurs péripéties de braguette en dévorer
ben et aux mains
de leurs guéguerres leur nostalgie de
militaires ne la larme à la paupière les
hommes virilité en bandoulière
rouler en bandoulière
et on y est
les hommes
il
traîneront de paix des vents d'est tout
est complet à me tordre or ces deux là
non
j'aime les femmes comme des fous c'est
si pervers mais c'est si doux enfin quoi
c'est pas comme nous les hommes
les femmes à la folie pas si venue elle
est jolie
le lit des hommes on va dire ou au
boudoir
à la torture aux trottoirs même les
femmes sans espoir les eaux
prostituée
pénélope apprivoisé ou
diop les femmes sont les [ __ ] pour
les hommes
793 je crois qu'on fait la femme et du
roi
la ration des droits de l'homme
c'est depuis 2000 ans je pense qu'une du
cafi de temps silence les fameux
tailleur et de france les hommes
sont abattus les tibétains
dans ces cas c'est les africaines sont
alignés
jenks les eaux
son 1000e voile aux algériennes la
chasteté au châtelaine et le tablier
amène trésor
excusez moi mais elle me gras ma pauvre
peau de phallocrate dans la région de la
prostate des hommes
excusez moi mais je me tire sans à
regret sans un soupir que votre mafia
votre empire des hommes
à chacun sa révolution en revanche
seulement des compagnons qui partage
l'indignation d'un homme à chacun sa
révolution
aurais-je seulement trois compagnons qui
partage l'indignation
un homme
on compterait pas mal manu oui c'est mon
troisième fils il fait des battes pour
l'instant puisqu'il est tancé mais je
suis très contente parce que c'est le
seul de mes fils qui aiment la musique
dans la musique qui va jusqu'en composés
qui chantait et ça je veux dire ça me
fait vraiment très plaisir en l'ordre du
jour très rapidement c'est évidemment le
cola des résultats et puis le soir très
souvent eh bien on est entre filles de
choisir les secrétaires nationales et là
on serait unie tantôt au local de
choisir le tantôt chez moi et ça
commence à 8h30 et ça finit rarement
avant minuit ce colloque international à
l'unesco les 5 6 et 7 octobre s'est fait
ces lampes en maintenant le bouquin que
sans gallimard qui sera prêt qui sera
prêt le 13 pour nous mais qui te rend
que dix jours après et ça c'est un peu
tard pour le débat à l'assemblée alors
ils vont organiser la vente des
militantes avec notre section où il faut
former les équipes faire partir et
lettres pour les sections pour qu'ils me
disent combien de
woerth et puis il faut y aller
bien en revoyant les équipes qui avaient
déjà fait la vente pour les bras et
femmes s'étaient créés tout et puis les
tables rondes auxquelles on va
participer le journal bien entendu par
le journal de choisir mais je crois que
ça doit se faire via rail le chili parce
que c'est quand même important de vous
dire que madame ariane idée la veuve du
président est venu solliciter l'appui de
choisir actuellement il ya une lutte des
femmes filiale contre la dictature et
les avocats de choisir nous envisageons
d'aller au chili comme observatrice si
cela est possible alors maintenir en bon
ce que vous pouvez faire dans l'immédiat
ça serait d'envoyer des lettres des
délais g et redone d'après corps est la
personne qu'il faut s'adresser plus de
plus aura deux femmes que ce sera utile
pour les femmes chiliennes qui luttent
et qui sont très isolés
je déclare ouverte ces assises de la
paire mesdames messieurs
pourquoi sommes-nous aujourd'hui réunies
ici
et bien pour parler d'un des problèmes
les plus graves qui puissent occuper les
hommes et les femmes d'aujourd'hui celui
de la paix je participe à des réunions
publiques à des conférences par exemple
aux assises pour la paix à l'unesco
ce qui me paraît être une très bonne
idée à condition qu'on faisait des
conclusions concrètes pour cette paix
dont tout le monde parle
la peine doit être à tout prix
sauvegarder mais il ne suffit pas de ne
pas vouloir la guerre la guerre éclate
selon la formule employée en français et
il faut éviter écarté éliminé mettre au
ban de l'humanité
tout ce qui pourrait être l'étincelle
qui la ferait que
les assises pour la paix on en parlera
tout à l'heure de leur utilité de leur
portée par avec marek halter
on vous a vu à une réunion de choisir
quelle est l'activité de choisir en ce
moment en dominant disons après
l'avortement après le violent d'ailleurs
j'ai même pas si je peux dire après ce
matin ils ont gagné non aucune des deux
que vous venez d'énumérer voudrait mieux
que moi elles reviennent d'une manière
cyclique l'avortement on va en discuter
et le viol c'est loin d'être gagné mais
ce que je crois que ce qu'on essaie de
faire à choisir je suis un peu ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est d'élever un
petit peu la réflexion et de qui est un
changement qualitatif et quand on apprit
initiative énorme en étant donné nos
moyens et nombre de filles que nous
sommes à travailler régulièrement ya pas
de permanente à choisir on travaille à
en plus après le travail les enfants le
mari et les problèmes oui mais il n'y a
pas une seule permanence je veux dire
pour faire des permanences au local de
choisir c'est à tour de rôle on peut pas
et là nous avons pris et nous avons
voulu faire ces assises ce colloque
international justement avec comme thème
choisir de donner la vie c'est un livre
l'enquêté oui là oui je me rends ce qui
est devenu justement étant d'un niveau
et la réussite
gallimard à pul
le sortir très vite tellement vite
d'ailleurs que c'est même un miracle et
je dois dire que c'est du nil gallimard
ni à choisir c'est du halal à l'équipe
de la prime riz de saint-amand qui est
ça je trouve ça assez formidable à
regarder le contenu a compris que
c'était fondamental que ça sorte
avant la discussion à l'assemblée parce
que c'est un peu d'ouvragés de recyclage
il ya presque tout le dans le point et a
décidé ils ont voté de travail et jours
fériés samedi-dimanche ans novembre et
jour et nuit pour que ce livre sorte et
il est sorti ce gars de la joyeuse que
se livrent les loisirs de c'est grâce au
pouvoir qu'on a sur son travail je crois
que c'est très important lire dès que
vous êtes intéressés on travaille plus
de la même manière on est plus on ne vis
plus un boulot on sait à quoi ça sert
avec l'enfant en couverture qui tient à
bout de bras une assiette dessiné par
picasso avec eux les verts d'eluard qui
sont la devise de deux chevilles
il me faut promettre et donner la vie
que pour la perpétuer comme on perpétue
une rose en l'entourant de main heureuse
voilà donc l'activité dominante de
choisir en ce moment c'est ses sorties
c'est de nouvelles et de nouveaux
combats de nouvelles étapes
éventuellement faire mieux connaître
peut-être des fléchir que vous avez
organisé un changement je vous dis lyria
la rue pour l'un des prestations puis à
la réflexion et on essaie de faire les
deux mais peut être en privilégiant la
réflexion est alors le viol d'une de vos
grandes batailles pour le faire
reconnaître comme un crime
est ce que c'est ça aussi c'est une
bataille gagnée ou pas d'accord non plus
non on est loin d'être gagnée vous savez
on a vraiment dit à peu près tout et le
contraire sur le viol par exemple vous
disiez bon c'est passé c'est en cour
d'assises
ça devait être en cour d'assises de
pique le code pénal existe parce que
c'est dans le code pénal mais on a
considéré que c'était pas un crime que
c'était pas suffisamment important au
fond comme infraction par les honneurs
de la cour d'assises et ça a été
systématiquement correctionnalisé ce qui
est bon contre la loi de ça mais ce qui
est un signe de culture un signe de
mépris de la femme parce que on était
jugé les violets venait dire ce qui leur
était arrivé entre un accident d'auto et
une paire de gifles quelqu'un vous voyez
donc on a fait la bataille pour que le
viol devenu un procès comme jeudi au
procès explication plus qu'un procès
expiation voilà c'est je crois que c'est
tout le problème
et on croit avoir gagné des étapes vous
savez on ne s'est battu contre le huis
clos parce que le big lots et tout le
monde l'avait reconnu le huis clos
finalement profiter plutôt à l'accusé
car quand la violer avait une courage
soutenu par nous d'ailleurs de venir
expliquer ce que c'était pour que ça ne
se reproduise plus le moins possible et
elle voulait bien sûr que ce fût public
or on en donne et le huis clos alors on
s'est dit bon ça y est elles ont gagné
la bataille à plus de huit lots les
propositions de lois qui sont à
l'assemblée le projet gouvernemental
d'ailleurs supprime le huis clos sauf si
la victime le demande
il ya une série d'autres propositions
qui sont dans les règles en effet alors
dans les faits moi je vais vous dire je
vais vous dire quelque chose de parler
de quelque chose de très actuel limoges
limoges jugement cour d'assises de
limoges trois jours de procès lundi
mardi mercredi jeune fille elisabeth
l'employée de maison 1800 francs par
mois je crois et puis trois violeurs
mais trois violeurs
dubreuil guerre de la guerre aux nières
et ainsi de suite qui comparaissent
libres alors ne sommes plus du tout dans
le même registre on est dans la haute
société
alors trois violeurs libre l'avocat
général ne s'est jamais opposée à la
remise en liberté que nous non plus
d'ailleurs par principe
ils comparaissent libres première chose
huis clos huis clos pourquoi n'y a pas
de mineurs elisabeth s'y est opposé la
victime mais on a prononcé le huis clos
aux applaudissements de la famille des
accusés deuxième chose ils sont
répondent oui à toutes les questions et
la cour d'assises dit oui tentative de
viol louis attentat à la pudeur parce
que la sphère et or ils ont emmené cette
gosse dans une écurie parce que l'un des
deux est monté dans un manège c'était je
veux dire des gens des notables et bien
oui au viol les condamnations deux ans
avec sursis
alors si c'est oui pourquoi est-ce que
ça c'est vrai que le projet de reparler
de la justice de classe enfin pour
travailleurs immigrés encore qu'il faut
bien le dire une violent porte pas
souvent en tout cas dans les
statistiques bien je pense qu'il en a
elles réunissent ou 15 ans de réclusion
mais là nous étions et les témoins 20
témoins pour redescendus de leur château
de des médecins des architectes et mamie
un juge d'instruction qui à la dernière
seconde heureusement n'est pas venu mais
tout le monde était prêt pour dire que
puisqu'on appartenait à cette classe là
violeur peut être mais on ne pouvait pas
le payer par des années de réclusion
alors je vais vous proposer un document
terribles auxquelles je pense vous
n'adhérez pas mais c'est pour le plaisir
de la contribution le viol ailleurs et
ailleurs c'est en chine
on va voir document vous voyez commentée
par la télévision chinoise
des violeurs désigner à la vindicte
publique dans un stade ont été condamnés
à mort un peu comme aux jeux du cirque
aux applaudissements laffont on y voyait
ils ont été emmenés en bus en voiture
c'est un document que la télévision
chinoise a filmé et volontairement
diffusé dans tous les pays
vous voyez on est là en voiture on les
deschamps et ils vont être mises à mort
voilà voilà
alors vous avez dit un jour jamais je ne
défendrai un violeur je pense que vous
ne pensez pas de ça non ce que je veux
dire c'est ce que vous montrez là
j'entends dire c'est pas documents sur
le viol est un document sur la chaîne de
mort et si non il va d'abord non mais
parce que pourquoi le viol
on n'aurait été que vous auriez eu la
même scène pour autre chose sûrement
pour un meurtre pour une un délit
d'opinion politique comme ça peut se
passer et bien j'aurais eu la même
horreur et ce qui est symptomatique
c'est qu'on en a fait un document sur le
viol
et ça c'est tout ce que nous combattons
vous veillez je veux dire c'est ce que
dès qu'une chose a trait au viol on veut
en rendre responsables les femmes de
salé chinois lui ment sur le viol
s'épanouit non mais je vais dire des
fusibles présentés sur des viols
je le représente tel qu'on l'a reçue de
la télévision chinoise mais ça n'est pas
nous financions de viol ce sont des
hommes qui ont sont qui ont été reconnus
coupables d'un crime le viol est un
crime
disons comme les autres pour moi pire
mais comme les autres et qui ont été
d'une manière absolument barbares
condamné à mort et exécuté mais je crois
que la halle commentaires qu'on peut
faire si ça c'est sur l'exécution et la
condamnation en a le niveau de
civilisation des pays qui comme de
nombreux heurts ont encore aux encore
condamnés à mort et exécutés car vous
savez qu'on exécute en exécuter ya pas
si longtemps
mais quand vous disiez jamais je ne
défendrai un violent oui parce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que l'avocat ou
l'avocate et maîtresses ce total de 2 de
ses choix est vraiment choisi parmi les
causes qu'elle soit défendre ah oui gaïa
le choix et puis ce qu'il y avait deux
choix à faire c'est que je ne demanderai
jamais défendre une cause injuste n'ont
jamais parce que il faut pas il faut pas
que les avocats passent pour des
victimes
si pour des saints n'ont ni pour 10 en
somme rien de tout cela mais je veux
dire que vous pouvez dire demandé au
bâtonnier d'abord vous pouvez refuser un
dossier mais vous pouvez être commis
d'office c'est-à-dire qu'on vous ordonne
quelques-uns mais là encore notre
déontologie et bien que quand c'est
contre votre conscience ou vos
convictions
vous dites non de la même manière
j'aurais pas défendu un sait si on ne
m'aurait pas obligé je défendrai pas un
violeur je dirais d'ailleurs que pour
une bonne défense il vaut mieux que ce
soit pas moi car il faut un petit peu
sentir
pour les expliquer alors votre prochaine
bataille vous allez défendre insoumis ah
oui je vais défendre mon ami jean fabre
devant le tribunal permanent des peuples
et d'amis qui se l'est jean fabbri est
un citoyen français insoumis qui a été
condamné par défaut à quatre mois
d'emprisonnement qui était secrétaire
général du parti radical ce petit parti
se prend maintenant une partie qui
devient important parti italien qui a
des députés à l'assemblée italienne et
député au parlement européen qui a été
pendant qu'il était à fresnes élu
président de ce même parti et qui entend
faire justement de son procès n'ont pas
son procès mais comme je le disais le
procès explications du droit à
l'insoumission de la non-violence de la
condamnation de la course aux armements
et comme il a raison comme il a raison
de de lier toutes les choses
lorca but qui a vu le dernier sujet je
sais vous intéresse particulièrement
mais pour le reste qu est ce que tu es
ce que vous avez fait depuis un peu plus
d'une demi-heure alors j'ai commencé par
une évocation de l'enfance 2
la limite je serai avec un tchador
c'était d'avoir avec un tchador suppose
une très bon c'est la robe qui se
transforme en robe d'avocate
et puis le rêve de ses ennemis c'est de
lui mettre le tchador un peu plus
bayonne et voilà alors ça c'est une
évocation de des bavures policières
maintenant on peut plus appeler la
police quand on est une femme il vaut
mieux appeler tout de suite gisèle
halimi voyez on pense que les bornes de
police soient branchés sur gisèle halimi
plutôt petit iglesias et l'évocation
aussi de votre passage en en algérie low
as we la bande de gaza ce même pas
volontaire pour viol et gisèle halimi
déjà ils avaient peur de personne mais
si dieu merci on vend tout à l'heure où
charlotte de turckheim vous avez vous
avez voulu qu'elle soit parmi nous oui
alors on va lui demander de me donner un
échantillon de ce qu'elle fait une gaffe
à la gare ddea texte fait une pièce
écrite par coluche et qui s'appelle la
fin du monde aura lieu le mardi
alors on va vous écouter et puis après
on vous demandera de nous rejoindre à
quel point je suis un petit peu embêté
là parce que on devait venir à 24 parce
qu'on les 24 dans la pièce policière et
puis il ya eu des histoires aussi
engueuler la télévision pas voulu payer
enfin bon alors on est venir à plusieurs
et puis finalement ben on est venu tout
seul quoi bon si vous n'avez rien perdu
la pièce et les poids terrible puis
alors les acteurs nul l'unm qui joue
avec nous
martin une [ __ ] à leur blonde
décolorée les cheveux jaune ptt châlons
réd elle a les cheveux raides
elle a une maladie de la tête ou chez
macway martin puis à leurs questions et
leur ont laissé en vie avec marc ela
elles sont les brasser du des caps
fourquet ce mail martine elle croit
qu'elle est danseuse elle a dû prendre
trois cours de danse quand elle avait 8
ans ça fait je suis point moi ça fait
longtemps un bas ça fait line renaud
habitait encore dans l'or quoi elle
croit qu'il est danseuse bon moi j'y
connais rien mais personnellement je la
trouve pas gracieuse voyais marquer elle
a fait ce qu'il a pu pour annie
gracieuse et martine elle a le menton
refait les dents refaites et les seins
refaits
c'est salon du bricolage et martine elle
croit qu'elle est danseuse en erreur
grave
tu parles elle voudrait jouer le rôle
une autre elle sait même pas qui allait
là je dis pas ça pour dire du mal
j'ai eu
pierre est moche en plus elle est moche
martin puis elle est chiante non pis
surtout et conquois martin lola qui joue
avec nous que j'aime bien moi j'en lui
qui s'appelle les gentils lui mais il
apporte toute sa tête
il a reçu un chien tu parles d'une tuile
il ya des gens qui reçoivent des tuiles
les jours de grand vent mais lui c'était
un chien le poids devant d'ailleurs
c'est un chien qui est tombé du
troisième il a éclaté sur la tête dit
lankais il a été coiffé par les boyaux
tient sur la saône est un géant lucas et
t'imagines le mec et la rancoeur et puis
le bronze et s'il arrive couvert de
goyon tiens voilà ils sont cons toute
façon moi ça m'est égal 1 parce que si
on continue à s'engueuler comme ça moi
je me barre
quand je m'en fous moi j'ai un métier je
suis secrétaire bon alors la seule chose
que je savais en sortant de l'école
c'était la sténo on parlait même en
sténo le parrain stand ça s'appelle on
la brave quoi c'est plus simple tiens je
vous donne l'exemple
qu'est ce que tu fais cet après midi
qu'est ce tu tapes alors qu'est-ce qu'il
ya du feu pour moi qui tient du pur non
c'est plus simple bon exemple de la vie
courante maintenant je pars chercher le
pain chez le boulanger jeunes cherchell
chez le boulot ayé c'est simple quand on
peut même faire du calcul mental en
stand alors un exemple je 12 gâte gens
mangent deux jambes qu'à ta montre qu'on
m'en reste un conte moral est bon il me
reste six ans j'ai douze gâteau j'en
mange 224 à montfrin éléments restent
aussi sans vous êtes nuls bon à l'autre
exemple alors suivez un jeu de pile est
déjà 40
je paie mes impôts dgi scar barre qu'on
en reste
comment est il a raison le monsieur zéro
les filets ça vaut plus que darryl
surtout ce dragueur de 40 ans vous ai
tenu un merci merci merci charles de
jack
au début c'est pas très tentant pour les
yeux pingwa je crois qu'il ya les gens
les gens qui tapent les uns sur les
autres qui n'a pas plu chez les femmes
que chez les hommes s'allume alors vous
êtes donc au café des diables et on dit
c'est la coluche féminine dont ça déjà
ça donne une image là c'était c'était
gentil et 10 ans était passable à la
télévision ya pire japy à beaucoup de
pire mais on n'a pas pu le passer à la
télévision je crois que c'est un pas été
possible vous aimez coluche et oui oui
oui oui non mais j'ai entendu ses
sketches je n'ai jamais vu sur scène
mais j'ai entendu certains de ses
sketches y en a de très bons en
particulier celui sur la police je
trouve qu'il est est très très bon parce
qu'il l'est
il pas la moindre vulgarité et c'est
quelqu'un et c'est quelque chose qui est
le don de l'observation et le rendre
avec ce sens de l'absurdité qu'il a
c'est beaucoup de talent ils vont fuser
parité non pas du tout mais cela dit non
mais je trouve ce cas-là de remarquable
c'est que non parce que je vous ai
écoutés ferrante moi je vous ai vu dans
les bonbons magiques
par exemple c'est pas ces lois date de
la vulgarité c'est le contraire la
peinture de cette vendeuse bon est ce qu
il ya de très excitant de très
exceptionnel chez elle du maire général
chez les femmes tout comme dominique
lavanant de ça c'est que on renonce les
femmes renoncent à ceux qui étaient
traditionnellement leur seule arme même
pour le spectacle ayant mines au décès
du bauchi grosjean voilà et et que la
majorité des femmes sont des femmes sont
pas des bourgeois sont pas des femmes
comme on voit dans les films la
télévision et sont plutôt des femmes
comme ce que j'avais mais vous
interprétez vous avez été le choisir oui
oui oui et militer bien bah oui je crois
moi je galérais tant que militants de
choisir mais j'étais très content le
sait que venus la voir parce que j'avais
été militante de choisir et qu'elle
avait du talent je l'avais vu après et
le heat encore ben oui je milite en
élite forcément on milite tout le temps
parce que en faisant ce que je fais je
trouve que c'est une forme de
militantisme l'aurait bien beau courage
il a aussi continué méditer bien et
laissez votre place d'être gentil marek
halter qui va venir nous rejoindre on
mettre plus sérieux marek halter qui est
peintre écrivain est utile de vous le
présenter qui a écrit le fouet les rois
et la vie incertaine de marque ou mahler
qui vient de paraître chez grasset voilà
marek halter vous
vous avez été à l'origine d'un beau
mouvement sur le boycott des la coupe du
monde de football en argentine
et là vous avez envie de faire quelque
chose à propos des jeux olympiques de
moscou ici je n'ai compris ses narines
avoir votre action en argentine non
c'est que chaque fois il faut il faut
quand même adopté notre notre action nos
possibilités
et puis aussi sensible je vais dire
qu'elle est les régimes totalitaires se
rassemblent parce qu'ils oppriment des
hommes mais ils oppriment des manières
différentes
alors en argentine effectivement les
gens disparaissent la nuit mais les
jours ils peuvent voyager ils peuvent
circuler les touristes qui allaient
peuvent sortir en union soviétique
les gens les hommes qui sont pas
d'accord avec les pouvoirs pour tout
simplement parce qu'ils réclament ils
demandent l'application de la loi sont
arrêtés par la police officielle
les touristes peuvent passer rendre
tranquillement cette difficile d'avoir
des visas alors boycotté
c'est un petit peu aidé les pouvoirs à
tenir ses citoyens en est car justement
à l'écart de tout ce qui s'est fait dans
le monde alors j'ai pensé que cette fois
ci il faudrait y aller on a ce demander
des visas cas l'union soviétique s'était
engagé à respecter la charte olympique
qui prévoit pas seulement les libre
compétition mais aussi des échanges
entre les zones entre les femmes et je
pensais que si de milliers des dizaines
de milliers d'hommes et des femmes
demande des visas pour se rendre à
moscou pour ces jeux olympiques alors de
deux choses l'une où l'union soviétique
30 paires de cette masse de touristes
inattendu et nous refuse des visas en
mettant en question ses propres
capacités d'organiser les jeux
olympiques ou alors ils nous laissent
veniez il manifesté avec sarah au prix
nobel de la paix pour les droits de
l'homme en union soviétique
si vous l'annoncer dès maintenant ils
ont toutes les raisons de nous refuser
mais de toute manière je pense que la
lutte contre le système totalitaire est
très dur faut beaucoup d'imagination
j'annonce certaines choses n'avancent
pas tout je pense que les actifs les
sportifs présents pourraient faire on
peut
comme comme amnesty international adopté
deux ou trois ou quatre prisonniers
politiques demander leur libération
avant les jeux olympiques
vous savez ce que répondent les sportifs
souvent ils disent nous on y va pour le
sport mais notre rôle n'est pas nous
mêler de politique est ce que vous avez
réussi à les convaincre ou est ce que
vous croyez qu'il faut les convaincre
mais je pense que déjà pour la coupe du
monde de football il faut dire nous
avions eu pas mal de discussions avec
des sportifs et c'était sportif en
général de professionnels et ils ont
fait des choses bien sûr n'ont pas
refusé de se rendre en argentine mais
ils sont quand même allés ils ont
demandé la libération des français
emprisonnés là bas ils ont quand même
réussi à libérer plusieurs
cette fois ci on a affaire à des
sportifs amateurs donc des hommes des
femmes comme vous et moi qui sont
engagés dans la vie quotidienne qui
travaillent qui journaux qui c'est vrai
c'est difficile de les demander à eux
qui se prépare depuis des années pour
participer à cette compétition n'est pas
allé mais attend comme qui en dehors de
la fonction de des sportifs
je suis persuadé qu'ils prendront une
position qu'ils allaient me qu'est ce
que vous pensez moi je m'interroge parce
que j'ai pas les idées claires sur le
moyen je suis bien sûr on a tendance à
être pour le boycott parce que faut pas
y aller parce que c'est une opération
prestige dans des ligues qui
embellissent les jeux olympiques
peut-être que si on avait boycotté les
jeux olympiques du temps d'hitler
peut-être que ça aurait servi à quelque
chose
en tout cas dénoncé parce que
l'argentine blitz est un c'est pas le
boycott de conseillère n'a pas été un
échec parce qu'il ya une telle je veux
dire on a tellement parlé c'est à ce
moment là qu la télévision justement a
diffusé des séquences sur les
prisonniers sur les tortures donc ça a
servi ce que je me demande si on n'est
pas arrivé au moment où il faut
peut-être cesser de faire du coup par
coup pour revenir et c'est pas si facile
mais enfin faire une espèce de chartes
non pas des droits de l'homme parce que
tout le monde
signe des deux mains c'est ça n'engage à
rien n'avait qu'un engagement de tous
les et de tous les états réciproque sur
un certain nombre de conséquences si ces
droits de l'homme sont violés
maintenant je comprends votre position
d'abord parce que témoins la scène
chercherait pas changé on cherche avec
toute manière mais je veux dire on
aurait quelque chose ou on ne seraient
pas les seuls à avoir l'initiative oui à
lorsque vous n'êtes pas la seule à
défendre cette position pas mal des gens
d'ailleurs beaucoup à ski qui a permis
d'accueillir allant dans ce sens mais il
me semble je ne suis pas sûr bien
attendent
je sais que les boycotts la campagne
pour le boycott en argentine a réussi
par titre on peut pas parce qu'on a
boycotté mais parce qu'on a réussi à
sensibiliser l'opinion publique
internationale sur ce qui s'est passé en
argentine
mais il faut voir aussi qu'on peut pas
répéter à l'infini les mêmes choses je
pense qu'il faut qu'on ait des
stratégies pour les droits de l'homme il
ya une stratégie c'est-à-dire que nous
avons affaire à des professionnels
quelqu'un de l'autre jour j'avais j'ai
eu une conférence pour donner une
conférence sur ce sujet à versailles
quelqu'un m'a dit la différence entre
l'argentine union soviétique c'est d'un
côté vous avez des amateurs de l'autre
côté des professionnels elle c'est vrai
nous avons des professionnels de gens
qui préparent ce jeux olympiques se
prépare ce genre olympique et mettent en
question comme tous les systèmes
totalitaires la halle à l'image des mata
supériorité de leur système justement à
partir de ce joli pic à partir du du bon
et d'une bonne manière des procédés
devant une bannière d organiser ces jeux
voulait les prendre à leur propre piège
et pense je pense que la force de
dissidents la force des gens comme sarah
rohff
c'est que justement il vient pas pour
dire vous savez on va on vous propose un
monde extraordinaire les bonnes et
universel un autre qui c'est lui qui
vous nous proposez il dit par nous
allons mettre des bombes pour détruire
vos systèmes il dit pas qui vais
remplacer brejnev ce qu'ils demandent
c'est l'application de la loi
l'application la construction soviétique
l'application de l'aqdr helsinki
l'application de la charte olympique
et c'est sa force je pense qu'ils ça
pourrait aussi la note
en l'occurrence je dis pas toujours en
l'occurrence si nous on demande aussi
l'application de la charte éthique
alors on met ça veut dire on met à
l'épreuve les l'union soviétique et son
régime
maintenant c'est aussi une autre manière
de mobiliser l'opinion publique
internationale
on ne peut pas rêver venir chaque fois
en dix ans boycott car l'opinion
publique sait déjà qui une fois ça n'a
pas réussi
nous savons qu'il a réussie était rod
sur un autre etarra mais le public qui
sait qu'on n'a pas réussi jeudi à me
parler de coup par coup tout à l'heure
moi je me demande c'est pas une façon
quand même de dédouaner l'argentine par
rapport à l'union soviétique ou e-bonds
l'argentine on a fait ce qu'on a pu
sympa marchés se sont pas des
professionnels fallu dire l'ennemi le
mal absolu salaire de l'union soviétique
l'argentine c'est le mal absolu non pas
du tout c'est ce qui se passe il faut il
faut quand même voir les choses en face
nous vivons dans une très grande
argentine c'est ce que j'essaie de
raconter dans mon dernier roman c'est à
dire qui est trois quarts de l'humanité
vit déjà en argentine sauver ce système
totalitaire qui chaque fois prennent une
autre forme
mais la répression l'art pression est la
même qui soit l'oppression de la femme
des juifs des minorités des gens qui
pensent un petit peu différemment parce
que ils veulent s'exprimer tout simple
nous sommes peut-être 14 ou 15 pays dans
le monde sur 140 150 où on peut parler
comme nous parlons maintenant entre nous
il ya encore cette démocratie dans
laquelle nous vivons n'est pas acquise
pour toujours elle n'est pas parfaite
nous devons pas seulement d
résister et dont défendent contre les
assauts de l'extérieur m contre les
dangers qui nous guettent l'intérieur
parce que ça reste sera donc la lutte
quand je dis maintenant l'union
soviétique j'abandonne pas à
l'argentière seyssel gelé ou bien
attendu en argentine les gens continuent
à mourir
c'est certain qu'on aurait libéré
quelques-uns il n'y a pas un col très
longtemps un ami pour lesquelles je me
suis battue depuis des années à copeaux
timmerman le directeur de l' opinion
celle journal libéral qui a tenu pendant
quelques années mais la lutte continue
les problèmes c'est que des gens comme
si c'est fini en permanence pour c'est
cela je veux dire que nous sommes peu
nombreux nous sommes ces gens de des
hommes des femmes qu'on appelle des
emmerdeurs qui vient chaque fois chaque
fois parler de tel ou tel problème quand
chaque français a ses propres problèmes
il ya la crise il ya le chômage est un
problème il ya un enfant qui est malade
et nous on vient les raconter encore des
problèmes plus graves plus terribles
ailleurs alors bien sûr on est des gens
qui dérangent et on peut pas déranger
tous les jours c'est vrai là aussi un
problème de stratégie on peut pas signer
toutes les pétitions pour tout le monde
alors chaque fois il ya effectivement
des luttes ponctuelles chaque fois il ya
des urgences et les urgences pourquoi ce
n'est pas que ce n'est pas urgent d
parler du cambodge
c'est très très urgent mais je vais dire
que chaque fois l'actualité nous permet
nous accrocher nous raccrocher à
l'actualité et pouvoir parler quand nous
parlons maintenant justement de jeux
olympiques de moscou
gisèle halimi les droits de l'homme ont
lieu tout à l'heure ça a était c'est
toujours un nouveau combat à la paix
aussi vous avez participé à des assises
sur l'appel une excuse mais savoir à
quoi ça sert oui je pensais que ça
pouvait servir
je crois d'ailleurs que sa soeur parce
que le fait que
on puisse se rencontrer comme ça venant
de tous les coins du monde avec ces pays
justement comme vous le disiez où la
démocratie est loin d'être une réalité
on peut le dire moi j'ai eu une longue
discussion avec elle touche à coup
pendant une demi heure
sur les goulags et je ne sais pas
peut-être vous surprendre mais il paraît
que j'étais conditionné par par le
capitalisme et tout ça est que les
goulags ça n'existe pas
non sans témoigner alors vous
comprendrez donc ça on voit que si les
choses avancent ou pas ce qui m'a déçu
dans les assises pour la paix c'est
qu'il y avait six femmes là-bas c'est
pas beaucoup sur 80 il est fier mais
avec 70 6 femmes et pas mal je veux dire
il y avait françois giroux il y avait
ici bas menuhin
il y avait corinne day souza qui est une
une femme très remarquable indienne qui
a même présidé une séance nous sommes
toutes intervenus nous avons tout fait
des propositions un petit peu différente
de ce que les hommes ont fait parce que
les hommes c'est toujours les mêmes
formules incantatoires la paix la
liberté la dignité nous avons posé des
choses et bien je sais pas si vous avez
vu ça dans la presse ou ailleurs mais
nous sommes invisibles les jardinautes
ibn e n'exigerait pas envie de vous dire
est ce que c est ce que si le résultat
des assises pour la paix avait été
positif avec une répercussion formidable
et avec enfin en réagissant groupes de
pression et que seuls les hommes y
participer est ce que ça aurait été très
grave je dirais la limite
l'objet était moins de faire participer
les femmes à ces assises que d'essayer
d'avoir une action quelconque positive
même jeu fut-elle l'action des hommes
moi je pense que les deux choses sont
très liées justement c'est ce que je
veux dire c'est que les hommes ont fait
la preuve de leur faillite tumultueuse
vraiment le monde des hommes ne prend
aucun risque quand il s'agit de la paix
d'un problème comme celui là de demander
aux femmes pour qui la paix je le disais
c'est une forme physique c'est un ventre
après que tu ouvres on lit ce heureux
quand on a choisi de de la voir comme ça
donc on prenait aucun risque avoir les
idées des femmes et le changement du
changement justement à fait peur mais
d'autre part il faut bien dire que ce
que fait l'unesco est tout à fait
différent comme mode de qom et chant
riehl ça peut ça peut ne pas être
inutile je regarde simplement que les
femmes elle n'est elles n'ont pas existé
je veux dire et il est même rejet mais
relevé dans un journal du soir
une phrase entre guillemets mise dans la
bouche d'un participant
j'ai reconnu parce qu elle s était la
mienne mais c'est pas du tout les droits
d'auteur que je réclame et je veux dire
n'était pas pensable qu'une femme ait pu
dire ça donc on l'a mis dans la bouche
en participant à ces faits il me semble
un petit peu peur quand on commence à
organiser les assises pour la paix ceux
qui on est con est tout près de la
guerre je vais dire que chaque fois
quand quand c'était pas une action
individuelle quand c'était pas vraiment
un engagement de personnes deux femmes
ou deux hommes
mais quand commencer à organiser une
discussion sur la paix c'est que la
guerre était déjà à l'horizon
merci marek j'espère que votre message
sera entendu
on vous rend à vos activités à vos taxes
et de peintres et de romance et gisèle
halimi dans votre panthéon dans vos
grand homme je m'attendais à trouver les
grandes femmes et puis j'en ai pas
trouvé beaucoup m'avaient dit et loire
flora tristan oui 521 nicolas ii sa
c'est pas rien nous avons plus de
grandes femmes ni la vôtre c'est le fait
que l'histoire des femmes personne ne
l'a encore jamais écrits de vire même
quand elle existe et elle a été occulté
la culture elle vient pas d'eux je veux
dire même quand on a fait la culture
même quand on a fait l'histoire
tenez je lisais c'est un livre d'andré
michel hexion le féminisme qui est
excellent et bien j'ai appris en la
lisant que par exemple l'agneau mystique
devant de vanhecke que tout le monde va
voir et bien avait été en grande partie
par sa soeur mais on ne savait pas
savais pas qu'il y avait une femme soeur
de la nec qui avait ce talent alors
eluard et le ar alors et lui à je dois
dire que tu as peut être que je connais
bien que j'aime beaucoup la preuve c'est
qu'on lui a emprunté la devise de
choisir que oui city tout à l'heure je
n'ai connu que j'ai connu mieux grâce à
claude faut qu'ils aient dit
l'enseignement mari lorsqu'il était au
sein d'al avait fait venir rester
responsable des activités culturelles il
avait 18 ans et
il lui a radié très persuasif puisque
claude adhéré au parti communiste l'a
quittée quelques dix années plus tard
et aussi grâce à dominique et loire qui
sa femme pour moi ça devrait effacer sa
femme je veux dire celle qui
l'accompagné jusqu'au bout du chemin et
ça c'est autre chose que de faire des
parties sur un liste et je dois dire que
j'ai connu tout à fait autrement il ya
des choses que je n'aime pas beaucoup
chez lui par exemple ses poèmes à
staline je n'aime pas aussi son côté un
petit peu l'amour des femmes vous savez
comme breton un peu mon ma femme aux
épaules de champagne vide on a consommé
tout de suite soit ni voile ni moi tels
que gmail et youtube mais en dehors de
ça le poème liberté moi je laime parce
que c'est pas un poème politique comme
vous savez d'ailleurs il n'était pas
écrit pour la liberté mais pour c'est un
poème d'amour
c'est pour ça que ça une telle c'est
écrit anouch sa précédente femme est
simplement il a changé non lieu de nous
presser devenu liberté alors d'un mot
sur flora tristan et puis flora tristan
c'est une très très grande je veux dire
c'est une femme à qui on n'en pas juste
pas là si c'est pas la plus grande des
femmes de lettres et c'est pas la plus
grande féministe
moi je crois que c'est probablement la
plus grande féministe pour son époque
vous savez 18 cents et quelques abritant
un passionné pinzi pattern une vie
passionnée une vie faite d'amour de
voyage de pérégrinations de recherche et
c'est celle qui quand même trente ans ou
moins
jean-marc touya dans le capital a trouvé
la formule justement de l'exploitation
des ouvriers celle des femmes qui a eu
l'idée de la pétition pour le
rétablissement du divorce la pétition
contre la peine de mort la femme c'est
quoi dit elle la prolétaire du
prolétaire et cette formule est
extraordinaire je sais pas une formule
seulement
c'est quand même elle qui l'a trouvée
avant le manifeste communiste avant les
écrits de mars qui faut bien dire ne
s'occupait pas tellement de la femme
cabu vous occuper un peu des femmes
entraînant un peu vous vous en êtes
non mais j'ai toujours une mesure mesure
de retard parce que vous parliez tout à
l'heure
oui non mais c'est vers on revient en
arrière volontiers alors je propose nous
traduire parce que nous on voit pas très
bien où je propose une bille la
guillotine pour les violeurs alors on a
diet in paghjella louis mendy hâter une
minuscule on a cru bon et je crois que
gisèle halimi nader quand même nom et
qu'on en trouvait bien mouvement mais
alors c'est une réflexion sur les
tribunaux militaires pro 7 jan fabre
mardi prochain oui un tribunal de
militaires jugeant et militaires c'est
comme si
un tribunal de plombier zingueur juger
un plombier zingueur et c'est comme si
un tribunal de violeurs juger un violet
voilà c'est mon point de vue oui puis là
c'est une réflexion en entendant parler
marina qualitair je trouvais que il faut
écrire et lire parce qu'on va tout et
c'était bien c'était pas la peine que je
me fasse la tête de marc s'ils ne
connaissent même plus de plus passé il
veut pas passer la frontière
on le donnera marek halter avant qu'il
s'en aille
gisèle halimi vous m'avez dit que c'est
un fait un scoop que vous vouliez nos
faire part de plaidoyer vibrant
l'intention de faire pour un parlement
européen pour les femmes 1 qu'est ce que
c'est que ce contrôle ça c'est une
initiative de choisir et qui je crois
est bonne et qui marche alors c'est
suivent créé dans tous les pays d'europe
à l'europe des neuf même au delà
un rassemblement informel lien on va pas
faire d'élection ni rien fait par les
groupes de femmes qui se préoccupent
justement d'améliorer pas seulement
améliorer la condition de la femme et la
changer changer les rapports entre les
hommes et les femmes qui se réunirait
dans un contre parlement européen mais
contre ne veut pas dire pour démolir le
parlement mais qui serait en quelque
sorte un groupe de pression sur les
parlementaires sur les parlementaires
européens qui siégeraient ce serait de
rêve à strasbourg en face même de
l'autre parlement pour faciliter la
communication et qui prendrait
l'initiative d'une convention des droits
de la femme d'un certain nombre de
mesures vous savez je on avait déjà
choisir avait lancé l'idée d'un groupe à
l'intérieur du parlement européen des
droits de la femme
je viens d'apprendre que c'est chose
faite là c'est un nous faisons les
choses un peu plus plus largement et de
manière plus contestataire c'est à dire
comme nous ne sommes pas des élus comme
son pacha poté par les appareils
politiques
nous sommes donc libre d'inventer de
réfléchir et de faire que notre
invention notre réflexion passe dont les
actes avec les parlementaires européens
il ya déjà six pays qui ont accepté d'en
faire partie les petits bars menuhin dit
qu'elle me donner son accord sous
réserve d'en parler à un groupe de
femmes en angleterre pour langues
terre nous voudrions l'élargir aussi par
l'envoyé des pays comme la suède parce
que pour les femmes c'est pas mal et
dire qu'il y aura la clause que
j'appelle la clause de l'européenne la
plus favorisée vers le nivellement par
le haut chaque fois que ya des droits au
travail pour les femmes des droits aux
congés des droits à la contraception à
l'avortement prendre ce qui est le
niveau le plus élevé est le fère le
niveau le donner à toutes les femmes
europe et est ce que ça veut dire je
sais qu'elles sont pas très nombreuses à
strasbourg mais ça veut dire que vous ne
faites pas suffisamment confiance aux
femmes qui sont et qui siège au
parlement européen
non c'est pas le problème toute manière
le problème vous savez des élus des
élections à l'intérieur des partis
tout ça c'est un problème particulier on
n'est pas libre je n'en veux à aucune
femme de ne pas défendre autant que le
souhaiteraient le programme des femmes
elles sont elles sont femmes elles sont
pleines de bonnes intentions mais d'une
certaine manière elle ne sont pas libres
ne décide pas autant qu'elles le
voudraient
donc c'est plutôt être je dis que notre
furries et lyon non notre force et leur
force vous savez après tout ce que nous
avons fait beaucoup de femmes dans les
partis ont fait paraître des manifestes
vous avez dû lire le parti socialiste le
parti communiste pour dire heureusement
que nous existons heureusement car ça
leur a permis d'élever un petit peu le
temps à l'intérieur de la réunion est de
dire que les femmes ça compte
avant quand même l'actualité et
l'actualité c'est l'iran s'est beaucoup
de choses mais c'est aussi une actualité
qui qui vous concerne directement
c'est l'avortement la semaine prochaine
à l'assemblée alors d'un mot et
rapidement parce qu'on qui concerne
toutes les femmes de ce pays à ce moment
alors le
et la position de choisir elle avait la
position de choisir c'est la
reconduction de la nouvelle dans son
principe avec les amendements très
important et d un moment certains en
étendant aux recteurs tenait à la
conversion le groupe
vous savez qu'ils étudient soit dit en
passant ce groupe est composé de neuf
députés mais à neuf formes n'y a pas une
seule femme pour essayer de voir
comprendre comment on peut améliorer
cette loi alors très vite les
amendements les plus importants sont
d'abord le remboursement par la sécurité
sociale je veux dire franchement je
trouve scandaleux que ça ne soit pas
parce que je nie stentys illogique savez
un c'est un acte médical de tous les
actes médicaux sont remboursées trois
l'avortement ne le sera pas on l'a dit
pourquoi pour dramatiser pour que ce ne
pas banaliser ce n'est pas admissible et
il faut bien lire c'est toujours les
femmes les plus vulnérables
économiquement qui vont faire les frais
de cette de cette interdiction
deuxièmement de 10 à 12 semaines dit
choisi envoyer c'est pas réduire le
délai oui je dois dire en passant que
dans toute l'europe enfin dans les pays
où on pratique l'avortement
le 10 mai n'existe pas il semble
toujours quand il s'agit du foetus
français ou de la santé de la femme
française il ya des critères
particuliers dans les autres pays c'est
12 13 14 18 est loisible à quelque 12
semaines sous ce maillot de l'as et
l'avortement thérapeutique
mais élargie avec des indications des
médecins des visites un entretien et
troisièmement la clause de conscience je
crois que c'est très importantes à dire
qu'il à maintenir la menthe ni l'heure
actuelle un médecin 0,2 pour des raisons
philosophiques ou politiques ou
quelquefois même on a vu le pen dans le
défilé là on peut dire même des raisons
politiques d'extrême droite d'accord
très bien mais lui interdire absolument
de paralyser par son pouvoir son abus du
droit d'arriver doute un vide alors moi
je dis une femme en détresse dit la loi
veulent femmes en détresse et une femme
en danger
quand on fait en sorte qu'on ne parte
pas secours à une femme en danger
et bien c'est l'article 63 du code pénal
ces refus de porter secours à autrui
on doit être poursuivi ce n'est pas
acceptable
et à votre avis l'assemblée va répondre
quoi ils votaient quoi à mon avis je
crois j'espère que le principe de la
reconduction sera à l'omi mais il faudra
des amendements sérieux quand même parce
qu'il n'y a pas de réseau savent qu'on
prendrait bien la position de
l'opposition des communistes socialistes
qui disent il n'y a pas de réseau
création une opération prestige pour le
gouvernement car ça fait libérale et
tout ça si les femmes ne profite pas
d'une amélioration de cette loi donc si
a pas d'amendement mais qu'elle ré avoir
invité d'une telle responsabilité mais
la respecte et partagez là je veux dire
vous proposé l'amendement aussi
autrement il ya situation de blocage
dont l'opposition n'est pas seulement
responsable
halak en 16 années nous rejoindre est-ce
que vous avez tas de choses à dire et
gisèle halimi vous avez écouté avec
attention aux jeux avec attention et pas
être méchant avec une face et avec il en
méchant non d'ailleurs c'est pas ça mais
j'ai entendu beaucoup de choses sur le
principe je n'ai aucune objection
seulement elle y est une chose difficile
qui s'appelle le principe de réalité
ce gaz entendu par exemple évoqué à
propos de limoges la justice de classe
ce qui est parfaitement vrai seulement
les femmes ont présenté des candidates
aux élections et vous êtes trop fine
politique pour ne pas savoir que ce
faisant premier tour si vous deviez
affaiblir quelqu'un c'était
nécessairement l'opposition et pro
parler clair le parti socialiste qui me
paraît plutôt généralement parlant plus
favorable à cause des fans que la
majorité
quand je voulais savoir si quand vous
avez dû présenter des candidates vous
étiez conscientes de ce risque ou non le
premier repart et si vous étiez
concentre pourquoi vous l'avez fait
quand même oui mais je suis pas tout à
fait d'accord avec vous bien parce que
ce que nous faisions au premier tour
comme les écologistes comme toutes les
candidatures c'est prendre la parole
c'est bien d'accord là c'est une tribune
très probablement oui m'enfin prendre la
parole de manière à mettre dans
certaines circonscriptions le parti
socialiste qui est en gros le même look
droite de vous vous avez des exemples si
on prenait leur jeu l'avait fait à la
main aux élections il ya quelques cas en
tout cas c'est à risque que vous
pourriez vous nous l'avons fait nous
avons été très excédés contrairement à
ce qu'on pense on dit des femmes qui se
présentent aux élections ça peut être
aussi intelligent aussi bon stratège
politique que des hommes et par
conséquent avant de le faire nous avons
réfléchi au problème nous en avons
discuté pas seulement entre nous mais
avec d'autres et je crois que la ligue
ordinaire c'est un problème quand même
mais j'ai pas dit qu'il n'est pas si
j'ai pas d'accord sur leurs commentaires
que vous en faites jeudi qu'un navet
nous étions assez intelligente pour le
poser en termes de problème essayez de
le résoudre
on n'est pas allé comme ça à
l'aveuglette et là ce que nous avons
fait je crois c'est populariser des
thèmes tenait au moment de ces élections
le programme commun des femmes d'avant
sortie pour ça si on leur promet
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas toutes les
propositions de choisir son reprises
pour être très franches d'ailleurs pas
seulement par l'opposition
surprise à peu près par tout le monde
il ya donc un travail que nous avons pu
faire grâce à la tribu que nous avons
eues
est ce que vous envisagez de présenter
un candidat ou une candidate excusez-moi
résidentiel résidentiel tiens c'est rien
ça faudra qu'on demande à choisir
lorsqu'elle pas si c'est pas moi parce
que là c'est qu'un petit nom mais j'agis
rejet par rome de personnalité parce que
vous savez que la par exemple pour d'ex
politique français actuel
vous pourriez peser très lourd comme les
écologistes d'ailleurs il n'ya pas
d'innocents gentil pas d'innocence qui
m'étonne beaucoup c'est qu'un mouvement
qui est en lui même un mouvement de
culture d' équilibre sociologique
descend dans l'arène politique sans
passer par le traditionnel et vient les
modifier or il ne peut pas ignorer en le
faisant qu'ils les modifie
nécessairement dans un certain sens oui
vous avez dit les choses très bien je
veux dire c'est exactement ce qu'on
voulait faire
l'arène politique mais pas la reine
politicienne oui l'arène politique la
politique c'est notre affaire à nous les
femmes nous en faisons tous les jours
mais nous refaisons d'enfer à travers le
canal jaillir des partis mais c'est pire
que le canal des appareils de parti
enfin écouter qui sont quand même deux
structures masculine madame l'équipe
minime hollande l'homme au siècle
dernier
nous voulons modifier ça je veux dire
c'est pas parce qu'on fait un constat
qu'ont l'acceptent se battre s'ils
pouvaient le constat et dire on en n'est
pas satisfaite
est ce que vous croyez vraiment de
laisser tel un cancer espérance que les
femmes sont une force politique en tant
que tel autrement dit une femme est
d'abord à l'état une prolétaire une
femme de la bourgeoisie enfin elle être
aussi cela
est ce que vous croyez vous pouvez
étendre votre action qui en elle-même
est parfaitement justifiée au niveau
politique sans finalement contre le
risque de déformer dangereusement les
règles du jeu politique dans une
démocratie
écoutez moi je crois que la question
vous me posez
pardonnez moi de le dire les pas
nouvelle nous a été fouillé et elle est
très importante
si je vous réponds très brièvement vous
prenez dans la même classe sociale un
homme et une femme
prenons comme disait flora tristan de
prolétaires est-ce que entre les deux il
n'y a pas une discrimination ne
serait-ce que celle du salaire ne
l'embauchent de pas le droit de disposer
à son gré alors attendez si vous êtes
d'accord
si nous sommes dans la même classe
sociale je comprends plus votre question
c'est que la discrimination vient bien
du fait et du fait seulement que je suis
une femme puisque je le même statut que
vous mais parce que je suis une femme je
j'aurai 33 % moins de salaire j'aurais
pas le droit d'avorter et je n'aurais
pas le droit à la culture comme les
autres la lutte des classes voulait
vraiment la lutte des classes ou à la
coopération des classes vous voulez
vraiment opposé la lutte des sexes je ne
pose pas je dis que là c'est pas la
lutte jeudi que la lutte des femmes
englobe explique recouvre ce que vous
appelez et que personne n'appelle plus
aujourd'hui la jeune fille le portage
employer le mot pour ça oui j'aimerais
mettre des guillemets oui absolument
oui ça serait pas linverse absolument
pas je vais vous expliquer pourquoi en
quoi la lutte des classes répond-t-elle
du fait qu'une des ouvrières à 33 % de
salaire que l'ouvrier expliquez moi
parce que pour l'instant c'est toujours
la même place qui a été postée dans
l'aisance du pouvoir et parce que dans
les autres pays on l'a tenté de faire
quelque chose avait l'impression que les
femmes sont égales aux n'y a plus rien à
faire
lorsque la lutte des femmes et finit
dans les pays acp je le crois pas ça
mais pas sûr qu'elle fasse par une lutte
comme vous voulez l'amener bien mais je
vous embauche sait pas choisir je vous
enverrai gisèle halimi pour tenter de
tup absolument persuadé que vos talons
d'avocats dla reste apparemment ils
restent très sceptiques en tant que juré
il serait pas bon en fait on aurait juré
cabu le mot de la fin pour vous il ya il
n'était pas prêt cc
gisèle dans giselle évidemment j'ai
utilisé oui c'est vrai j'avais pensé
d'abord parce que l'avortement avant que
gisèle et obtiennent des choses
oui j'avais commandé mes aiguilles à
tricoter par correspondance et puis ces
comptes postiers se sont mis en grève
étaient périmés l'a7 j'ai pas fini c'est
un monument à la gloire de gisèle halimi
à bord ah ah ben arfa de gisèle le
déchirant sa robe en deux qui ont les
pour les peaux violet pour l'epo avant
t&c merci qui a vu les sommes finalement
peut-être sont un peu macho ils les
machos et un peu quand c'est c'ui meka
but à rattraper oui très bien
non que je veux dire est-ce que je peux
ajouter à vos emails ont vraiment à moi
je veux dire sommes nous seulement rené
char le plus grand poète vivant par nora
gand a dit ce qui vient au monde pour le
rien troubler ne mérite ni dégât ni
content ni nous ni égard ni patience et
ça c'est je crois ce qui est la lutte
des femmes pour les migrations
merci gisèle halimi merci d'avoir été là
vitesse et jeudi
[Musique]